monsieur damien abad à qui je souhaite
un joyeux anniversaire
merci beaucoup monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur premier ministre voit
le mode islamique polémique chez air
france les manifestations ostentatoires
de l'islam politique se multiplient dans
l'espace public de petits reculs en
grand renoncement au fil de ces trente
dernières années la france traverse
aujourd'hui une crise identitaire
profonde les valeurs fondamentales de
notre république sont attaqués et la
laïcité en tant que principe est bafouée
renier mêmes piétiner l'actuel débat sur
la mode islamique constitue la dernière
résurgence de ce malaise elisabeth
badinter a raison de dénoncer la
stratégie de certaines marques qui
investissent ce marché en europe parce
qu'il est lucratif
le voile n'est pas un objet de mode trop
de filles des quartiers se sont mises à
le porter uniquement en raison de
pressions communautaires des pressions
qui s'exercent en tout lieu à l'école
dans la rue à l'université dans les
clubs de sport à l'hôpital ou encore au
sein de l'entreprise et à ce titre nous
nous opposons à l'article 1er de la loi
une connerie qu'ils introduiraient le
fait religieux dans le code du travail
parce qu'en france on ne ferme pas son
magasin où son entreprise pour aller
prier parce qu'en france nous faisons
soigner indifféremment par un homme ou
par une femme
en france une femme n'a pas dissimulé ce
qui fait son identité sous un voile ou
un niqab en france
la république se vit les yeux dans les
yeux c'est ce qui fait la france
monsieur
le premier ministre il n'y a plus de
place pour l'angélisme de la bienséance
la bien-pensance
on sacrifie l'idéal républicain de la
france sous l'autel de l'islamisme
radical et du fondamentalisme religieux
il ne faut plus aujourd'hui passé sous
silence cette banalisation des vêtements
islamiques les discours anti france ou
encore les zones de non-droit et autres
maux l'indec français il est urgent
d'agir monsieur le premier ministre
quel est votre plan d'action pour lutter
clair si la parole est à dieu le premier
ministre manuel valls le président
monsieur abad d'abord un mot sur les
principes qui ont fait l'objet d'un
travail
reconnaissons le de très grande qualité
de robert badinter et de plusieurs
experts et principes notamment dans
nombreuses principes qui ont été
travaillés qui faisait référence à la
liberté d'exprimer ses convictions y
compris religieuses dans l'entreprise
mais qui rappelle aussi et surtout que
des restrictions à cette liberté sont
possibles au sein de l'entreprise
lorsque en cause le bon fonctionnement
de l'entreprise où l'exercice d'autres
libertés
l'employeur dispose donc d'un pouvoir
important en la matière et c'est ce que
voulait rappeler ce principe
à l'évidence il y à débat il ya eu un
questionnement est ici même ce sujet va
être traitée au sein de la commission
des affaires sociales ces principes
d'ailleurs d'une manière générale
c'était l'avis des partenaires sociaux
comme la part de beaucoup de
parlementaires qui suivent ces questions
pouvaient poser des problèmes en terme
d'application de la jurisprudence et
avec la ministre du travail nous faisons
confiance aux rapporteurs
christophe sirugue pour trouver des
solutions pour faire ou pour faire en
sorte pour faire en sorte qu'on trouve
de toute façon le bon chemin il
s'agissait là de rappeler le droit ce
qui veut bien dire monsieur abad
ce qui veut bien dire monsieur à battre
que
sur ces questions là dès qu'on touche au
droit au droit fondamental
on peut être très vite en difficulté
alors que alors que nous pouvons
ensemble me semble-t-il avancé pour
promouvoir la république et défendre
l'idéal de laïcité
vous avez dit il ya eu beaucoup de
renoncement mais dans cette enceinte
même il y a eu des lois qui ont été
votées et qui au contraire était bien la
démonstration d'une capacité du
parlement à répondre à ces défis
je pense à la loi interdisant les signes
religieux ostentatoires dans les
établissements scolaires et qui fut le
fruit à la fois des travaux la
commission stasi et de la commission
présidée par le président de l'assemblée
nationale jean-louis debré voté à la
quasi unanimité
je pense aussi à la proposition loi
interdisant le voile intégral dans
l'espace public donc non le parlement et
la société française me semble-t-il ont
suffisamment de ressources suffisamment
de fierté dans nos valeurs pour réagir
comme le peuple français a su le faire
et de quelle manière le 11 janvier 2015
comme après les attentats du 13 novembre
donc moi je crois monsieur abad et je
suis convaincu que vous aussi que nous
avons la capacité de répondre au défi
qui nous est posée et puis la laïcité
elle doit concerner toutes les atteintes
toutes les atteintes à ce principe
fondamental
faisons attention même si il faut être
lucide bien sûr par rapport à ce qui
nous est posée notamment la place de
l'islam dans nos sociétés en france en
europe et dans le monde
mais ce sont toutes les atteintes à la
laïcité qui doivent être bien entendu
dénoncer ne donnons pas le sentiment que
nous visons à travers tel ou tel propos
une seule religion enfin et je vous
réponds il y à un débat que je crois
pour ma part fondamentale en france en
europe et dans le monde et qui posait en
effet à l'islam et notre rôle nous qui
croyons valeurs universelles c2d d'aidé
les musulmans de france d'europe et dans
le monde à faire la séparation nette et
définitive avec ceux qui agissent qui
parle au nom de l'islam voire qui sèment
la terreur au nom de l'islam et c'est un
combat fondamental qui ne peut pas être
résumée ici dans une question réponse à
l'occasion de ces questions au
gouvernement un débat fondamental est
derrière ce débat fondamental ya la
question de la place de la femme de
l'égalité entre la femme et l'homme dans
nos sociétés et là où je vous rejoins et
nous pouvons nous retrouver
c'est quand les fait pas seulement le
voile intégral mais une manière de
revendiquer le voile islamique
une manière de le revendiquer comme un
signe politique qui est adressé jeté à
la figure de la république dans les
quartiers mais d'une manière générale et
les propos qui ont été ceux de la
ministre des droits des femmes
laurence rossignol était juste il y à un
moment où nous devons dire assez on ne
peut pas accepter que dans nos sociétés
on veulent effacer la femme de l'espace
public lui nier son identité
quelle que soit la forme et ça c'est un
combat que nous devons mener ensemble
devant le mener à l'école dans la
société dans l'espace public avec la
plus grande d intransigeance et nous
devons le faire en disant clairement
quel est l'adversaire et l'adversaire
c'est l'islamisme radical
l'adversaire c'est le salafisme
l'adversaire c'est ceux qui veulent
s'approprier l'islam et l'immense
majorité des musulmans de ce pays qui
croit en les valeurs de la république
qui croient en la laïcité qui pensent
que la france est le plus beau pays du
monde et qui doivent être défendus voilà
la tâche qui l'hôtel est la nôtre et
voilà une tâche je suis convaincu une
mission qui doit être celle qui doit
rassembler tous les républicains
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
paleta monsieur hervé paulo